okay
okay that wasn't bad that wasn't bad we
got through it
hey guys my name is scott i'm a tasty
producer today we're here at tasty and
we're gonna make a whole bunch of
cinnamon buns we're going to compare
homemade cinnamon rolls to store-bought
cinnamon rolls to see which ones are
tastiest first up we're going to try the
store-bought cinnamon rolls from a tube
then i'm going to recreate a homemade
cinnamon roll recipe that i made a few
months back as a tasty video and we'll
put those against the ultimate cinnamon
roll cinnabon to be honest i think if if
only for not having to open one of these
awful tubes i would say you should make
the homemade ones
this is tied with opening a bottle of
champagne so like pop open the can you
put them in a rack and then you get to
put them in the oven
cute
you have to ration your frosting as well
that's the other thing about the
store-bought one is you only get this
tiny tiny cup if you make your own you
can just like make a ton of extra and to
be honest there might have been enough
frosting in here but i'm someone that
always thinks you can have
more frosting i would definitely eat
this and it was super easy
all right so i'm just prepping my
ingredients for the homemade version
i think a lot of the comments that i saw
in that video were that it was like
super involved or maybe too involved it
is a dough that uses yeast and requires
like an hour to rise really that
shouldn't intimidate you at all it's
still really simple basic ingredients
once it's like just incorporated and
like you don't see any more flour it's a
clear dough then you just kind of cover
it and let it rise
[Music]
honestly the reason i made this video is
because i'm obsessed with cinnamon rolls
and i just wanted to learn how to make
like really good homemade ones
[Music]
i think i was going for that cinnabon at
home kind of recipe and when it tasted
just like it or at least what i think
was just like it i was like yeah this is
this is the recipe pretty easy it's
pretty quick and it's really really good
[Music]
so the only thing about using a knife if
you use a knife to cut it it kind of
like presses down pinches your cinnamon
buns not it's like perfectly round or
circular a good trick that i learned
after if you use unflavored dental floss
you don't want the mint one really
because you just don't want like unless
you want a mint cinnamon roll uh you
kind of come bring this in here kind of
like tie it like you're starting to tie
your shoelaces and then when you go to
pull comes in on itself and it makes
this like perfect cut and it keeps it
round and beautiful and nice and you get
that perfect spiral
now we're going to make our frosting
which is a good way to make your
cinnamon rolls really stand out
i'm probably going to get a lot of crap
for this but we're going to make a cream
cheese frosting because it's incredible
when paired with cinnamon buns
so we'll get these in the oven
that's about 20 minutes
wrong it's gonna be 25 to 30 minutes
looks so good also the best part is i
can just load it up with as much as i
want
[Music]
oh it's so light and fluffy this is
great
our last contender is going to be
[Music]
that wasn't good
our last contender is going to be
our last contender going gonna be
[Music]
this guy
come on
you get it wow
wait
this does look so good
um they're ooey they're gooey they're
super sweet so it's gonna be tough to
beat this but uh we'll we'll see if the
homemade version stands a chance uh
later on
[Music]
all right we've got
the canned one the homemade one and the
cinnabon one let's bring these to the
people
[Music]
it tastes like a cinnamon roll but it's
really dry it tastes like home
okay it tastes like home
looks
like homemade and it's like what your
mom or your grandmother would make
there's a like a little bit of
give to the dough it's kind of springy
it's very sweet so i'm i'm gonna say
that's the store-bought one
oh my god they're so good
we have more
this one looks really good i'm so
excited it is like
eating diabetes
tons of cinnamon and flavor
[Music]
the homemade for store-bought cinnamon
rolls i think personally
and just going around the office the
feedback is that maybe it doesn't taste
as good but i think the process of
making it the ease of like popping open
a can and sticking it in the oven and
you have cinnamon rolls under 20 minutes
like you can't beat that and then the
homemade one the cream cheese frosting i
think adds a lot but just like the airy
texture of the cinnamon roll i think
makes it worth it then cinnabun it's
like the perfect mall cinnamon roll it's
almost like a little too chewy though
for me like it's not like a light airy
bread just kind of all like one note of
like
goo so the canned one's great if you're
in a pinch cinnabun is great if you're
at a mall but if you've got the time and
you want to challenge yourself i think
homemade is the way to go you can get a
light airy fluffy texture you get to
load it up with as much icing as you
want and i think ultimately seeing this
start to finish is just like so much
more rewarding
oh look at that
that's so bad
[Music]
[Music]
you